does call of duty have a future on
playstation xbox boss phil spencer
reveals more and battlefield might be
going free to play
following this week's massive xbox news
there were questions regarding call of
duty's position as an xbox exclusive in
the future what microsoft gaming ceo
phil spencer made a statement that
appears to put those questions to bed at
least for now on twitter spencer said
quote had good calls this week with
leaders at sony i confirmed our intent
to honor all existing agreements upon
acquisition of activision blizzard and
our desire to keep call of duty on
playstation sony is an important part of
our industry and we value our
relationship well that's good to know
meanwhile other activision blizzard
brands remain question marks regarding
exclusivity these include diablo
warcraft overwatch tony hawk's pro
skater spyro crash bandicoot and other
dormant franchises like prototype and
singularity however if the bethesda
library is anything to go by there's a
pretty good chance most of these titles
will find their way to game pass
microsoft's activision blizzard
acquisition is expected to close in
fiscal year 2023 which begins later this
year and it must be approved by
regulatory agencies prior to being
official are you a cod fan on
playstation let me know if spencer's
tweet puts you at ease a little bit
in other call of duty news the series
might be stepping away from yearly
releases according to a report from
bloomberg high-level employees have
discussed moving away from the annual
release schedule as part of microsoft's
acquisition of activision blizzard
nothing is set in stone yet but the
report said quote there's a belief among
many call of duty developers that
releasing games at a slower cadence will
please players and help bolster the
franchise the report went on to say that
this change could happen in 2023 or
potentially later and claim 2022's new
call of duty game which is said to be
the sequel to infinity ward's hugely
popular modern warfare reboot is poised
to quote redeem the franchise's fortunes
it's no secret that battlefield 2042's
performance issues xp progression and
moderate amount of available content
have seen a declining player count for
the near future military shooter
according to industry insider tom
henderson ea has been quote very
disappointed with the game's market
performance and is considering
implementing some form of free-to-play
capacity within battlefield 2042 it's
worth noting that battlefield 2042 was
2021's fifth best-selling game in the us
however ea so far kept quiet on the
exact numbers for the title this week
has seen substantial content drops for
the game though as the new 3.2 update
went live and added a refreshed
scoreboard ui that fans have been
requesting since launch hit the comment
section let me know what you're getting
into this weekend is it playing death's
door is it playing extraction or is it
playing death's door it's on game pass
you have no excuse you should be you
should be playing everyone should be
playing that's am i right am i right i
think i'm right
[Music]
you